venezuela está viviendo sus peores
momentos el desastre es tan grande que
la que antaño era una de las compañías
de petróleo más grandes y poderosas del
mundo pedevesa hoy está prácticamente en
quiebra y cada vez tiene más problemas
incluso para extraer petróleo un momento
que la empresa de petróleo del país con
las mayores reservas de todo el mundo
tiene problemas para extraerlo pues sí
tal como lo escucháis en este vídeo os
lo contamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos creo que todos lo conocemos
venezuela está viviendo una auténtica
catástrofe un desastre no sólo económico
sino sobre todo humanitario
[Música]
un desastre tan enorme que ha provocado
que en los últimos años
atentos entre 3 y 4 millones de
venezolanos hayan abandonado el país es
decir más de 1 de cada 10 habitantes y
la verdad no puede sorprendernos fijaos
según las últimas estadísticas el 87% de
la población el 87% casi 9 de cada 10
venezolanos son pobres y ojo porque la
mayoría de la población de venezuela el
60% no sólo es pobre sino que vive en
condiciones de extrema pobreza
pero no sólo eso venezuela está en
llamas según los datos del observatorio
venezolano de conflictividad social en
2017 se registraron casi 10.000
protestas por todo el país más de 27 al
día y lo que es aún peor
[Música]
según datos de la ex fiscal general
luisa ortega desde 2015 la policía la
guardia nacional el ejército y los
diferentes servicios de inteligencia han
asesinado a más de 8000 personas por
supuesto la mayoría de ellas opositores
al régimen
crisis hambre violencia represión todo
apunta a que venezuela va a vivir
próximamente una crisis de refugiados de
dimensiones colosales porque amigos
seamos sinceros la cosa no pinta nada
pero que nada bien
veréis durante años la revolución
bolivariana de chávez maduro y compañía
tuvo un gran aliado y no hablamos de
cuba ni de rusia ni de cualquier otro
país sino del petróleo el oro negro que
financió la revolución durante mucho
tiempo los ingentes ingresos de esta
materia prima financiaron todas las
políticas del régimen sin que las
consecuencias importarán absolutamente
nada
[Música]
es decir que las fábricas cerraban que
la inversión extranjera salía huyendo
del país no importaba nada porque amigos
ahí estaban los dólares del petróleo sin
embargo ahora todo eso está a punto de
terminarse si en venezuela hay mucho
pero que muchísimo petróleo pero una
cosa es tener petróleo y otra muy
distinta a ser capaz de explotar lo
sabíais que presa está a punto de
colapsar prácticamente del todo atentos
e
[Música]
la caída de pedevesa
petróleos de venezuela pedevesa fue
creada por decreto gubernamental en 1976
para integrar todos los activos
petrolíferos nacionalizados por el
estado esta empresa pronto se convirtió
en un coloso de talla mundial
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sabéis por qué pues entre otras cosas
porque esta compañía posee las mayores
reservas del planeta y ojo que no
hablamos de poca cosa son más de
trescientos mil millones de barriles de
crudo certificados más que las reservas
de arabia saudita emiratos rusia o
cualquier otra potencia petrolera si es
verdad lo hemos contado aquí el petróleo
venezolano no es de la mayor calidad
pero no importa estamos hablando de una
cantidad impresionante de recursos casi
el 20 por ciento de todas las reservas
mundiales conocidas
pues bien el caso es que esta compañía
pedevesa alcanzó su pico de producción
en 1998 un año antes de la llegada al
poder de hugo chávez
en aquel momento pedevesa estaba
extrayendo tres millones y medio de
barriles diarios desde entonces las
cosas han cambiado bastante en 2013
cuando falleció hugo chávez
la producción se había reducido en un
millón de barriles al día un momento un
millón menos será acaso que al gobierno
bolivariano de hugo chávez no le gustaba
el petróleo sería cosa de algún
retorcido plan para diversificar la
economía venezolana pues lo cierto es
que no todo lo contrario y fíjate que a
pesar de todo nunca nosotros dejamos de
mandarle a ustedes
un millón y medio de barriles diarios de
petróleo en un negocio en el comercio
[Música]
hugo chávez quería elevar la producción
hasta los 5 millones de barriles el
problema es que simplemente no fueron
capaces de hacerlo pero si pensáis que
los resultados del comandante fueron
malos es que no habéis visto nada porque
desde que nicolas maduros llegó al poder
la producción se ha hundido hasta los 18
millones de barriles es decir mientras
países como eeuu han doblado su
producción venezuela produce la mitad de
petróleo que cuando comenzó la
revolución menudo éxito
[Aplausos]
y pensáis que esto es lo peor pues no lo
peor es que las previsiones son aún
mucho pero que mucho peores para los
próximos años
ahora bien llegados a este punto puede
que te estés haciendo una pregunta qué
diantres está pasando con pedevesa
[Música]
las claves de un desastre ha anunciado
la historia de pedevesa amigos ha sido
la historia de un desastre anunciado el
mejor ejemplo lo encontramos en la
refinería de paraguaná uno de los tres
mayores complejos de refinamiento de
petróleo de todo el planeta durante años
fue el orgullo industrial de venezuela
la joya de la corona sin embargo hoy
apenas opera al 15% de su capacidad y
todo tipo de accidentes son habituales
porque
no hay mantenimiento como tal chuparon
todo lo que pudieron de pedevesa sin
invertir ya no queda nada que exprimir
pablo céspedes operador de planta y este
no es un caso extraordinario lo cierto
es que la mayoría de las instalaciones
de la petrolera se encuentran en un
pésimo estado
a finales de octubre en el mismo
complejo de refinamiento de paraguaná la
refinería de amuay vertió la bahía más
de 200 mil galones de gasolina apenas
unos días después otra refinería del
complejo la refinería de cardón sufrió
un incendio que los bomberos apenas
pudieron contener por no tener ni
siquiera espuma con la que enfrentarse a
las llamas
y así suma y sigue pero como creéis que
se ha llegado a este punto construyendo
patria paso a paso vamos transitando el
camino
pues veréis el gobierno chavista siempre
vio a presa como una especie de vaca
lechera de donde poder obtener todos los
recursos que necesitaban para su
revolución bolivariana el problema es
que la industria del petróleo es una
industria que requiere muchas
inversiones inversiones que el gobierno
venezolano simplemente no quiso hacer
y todo eso a pesar de que endeudó a
pedevesa hasta las cejas por cierto
sabéis que deuda tiene hoy esta compañía
pues atentos al dato no hablamos ni de
mil y de cinco mil millones sino de
noventa mil millones de dólares una
fortuna tan grande que venezuela podría
haber comprado con ella multinacionales
del calibre de goldman sachs
nike o siemens que se dice pronto
[Música]
no me digáis que venezuela no hubiera
salido ganando pero pensáis que esto es
todo que va además utilizaron a la
empresa para enchufar colocar contratar
a miles y miles de partidarios amigos y
familiares con lo que pedevesa cada vez
tuvo menos y menos recursos y aún más
por si no fuera suficiente el régimen
chavista colocó en los puestos de
dirección a personal no cualificado y
sin experiencia al tiempo que despidió y
ahuyentó por sus ideas políticas a miles
y miles de empleados que sí tenían
muchísima experiencia sí así es cómo
pedevesa se ha quedado sin dinero y sin
recursos humanos ahora ya podemos
entender por qué la producción de
petróleo no hace más que caer por
supuesto las consecuencias de todo esto
para el país son terribles
[Música]
consecuencias
el petróleo es fundamental para la
economía venezolana sobre todo desde que
no queda ninguna otra industria en pie
la dependencia es tan grande que el
petróleo genera el 95 por ciento de
todas las ganancias en divisas
extranjeras en dólares por ejemplo
y estas divisas amigos son las que
venezuela necesita para poder importar
alimentos fármacos gasolina si venezuela
hoy tiene que importar gasolina o
cualquier otra cosa pero claro como la
producción de petróleo no hace más que
caer pues el país cada vez puede
importar menos cosas
y sabéis que como en venezuela ya no se
produce literalmente nada y hay que
importarlo todo el menguante dinero del
petróleo ya no da para pagar todas las
facturas pero claro como todos sabéis
cuando se gasta más dinero del que se
ingresa el dinero se termina y eso es
precisamente lo que le está pasando a
venezuela que según algunos cálculos
apenas cuenta ya con 10 mil millones de
dólares en reservas extranjeras
la cifra ojo más baja en 40 años es
decir cuando ese dinero se termine ya no
se podrá importar absolutamente nada más
que lo que pueda comprarse con lo que se
ingrese por el petróleo que es cada vez
menos veis dónde está el problema
[Música]
hasta ahora el gobierno de nicolás
maduro ha tratado de ganar tiempo
recurriendo a los mercados
internacionales para emitir deuda con
tipos escandalosos y en algunos casos de
hasta el 40% como ya vimos aquí en
visual político en un pasado vídeo
evidentemente amigos emitir deuda con
tipos implícitos intereses del 40 por
ciento supone ir de cabeza a la ruina y
en cualquier caso hoy ya no es ni
siquiera una posibilidad de hecho tanto
el gobierno de venezuela como pedevesa
están incurriendo en default es decir
que no están pagando sus deudas standard
and poor's rebaja a nivel de default
siete bonos soberanos de venezuela otra
vía que también han intentado ha sido la
del rescate chino y los chinos
respondieron y pusieron sobre la mesa
préstamos por más de 23 mil millones
pero todo tiene un límite y ya no están
dispuestos a seguir poniendo más y más
dinero por nada fijaos la petrolera
china sinopec demanda pedevesa por
deudas no pagadas la situación amigos es
tan desesperada que el gobierno de cuba
el gobierno de cuba ha decidido embargar
el 49% qué pedevesa tenía en una
refinería cubana como compensación por
deudas impagadas tal cual como lo
escucháis
ni cuba se fía ya del régimen de maduro
y así ni más ni menos es como ha nacido
la última ocurrencia chavista el petró
el petró
[Música]
como hemos visto cada día que pasa el
gobierno de venezuela tiene menos acceso
a las divisas extranjeras lo que
evidentemente es un problema enorme
porque sin divisas no hay importaciones
pero en esta surgió una idea nueva
las cripto divisas están de moda así que
por qué no lanzar nuestra propia cripto
divisa bolivariana el petró la creación
de la cristo moneda el peso que hemos
lanzado nosotros sustentado en riquezas
petroleras certificadas y que muy pronto
vamos a tus pensadas con riquezas de oro
de diamantes certificados de la
república bolivariana de venezuela claro
que el petró es una cripto divisa muy
particular entre otras cosas amigos
porque está controlada por el gobierno
de maduro en estas condiciones os hago
una pregunta estaríais dispuestos a
invertir un solo euro un solo dólar en
esta nueva cripto divisa o dicho de otra
forma podríais vuestro dinero en manos
del gobierno venezolano yo lo tengo
clarísimo ni uno
e
y precisamente porque nadie en su sano
juicio haría tal cosa es por lo que el
gobierno de venezuela ha tenido que
respaldar esta particular cripto divisa
con petróleo es decir cada petro estará
garantizado por un barril de petróleo de
las reservas petroleras de venezuela
reservas que por supuesto están en el
subsuelo claro de esta forma de algún
modo el valor del petró queda
aparentemente vinculado al de esta
materia prima
y voy a estar haciendo el niño el niño
feliz
petro la cripto novela para enfrentar a
su hermano que no ha podido ni podrá con
nosotros os parece que ahora suena mejor
pues espera de un momento porque no
podemos olvidarnos de un detalle un
detalle muy pero que muy importante las
reservas de petróleo amigos se
encuentran también bajo el control del
gobierno chavista y yo me pregunto
realmente crees que este gobierno va a
conseguir explotar esas reservas y aún
en el caso de que no lograra crees que
mantendría el respaldo del petró y la
tasa de conversión no se gastaría acaso
los recursos generados no impondría
nuevas restricciones o regulaciones que
le beneficiarán
y sobre todo para que el día antes
arriesgarse con los pedros por cierto un
apunte importante el petró no es
convertible es decir aunque
supuestamente esté respaldado por
barriles de petróleo
nunca lo podréis intercambiar por uno de
ellos ni por ningún título que acredite
un derecho sobre esos barriles el petró
es una cripto moneda que no es cripto
respaldada por reservas que no lo son
que sólo se puede monetizar con
producción que está colapsando y
expedida por un gobierno en default y
sin dólares francisco monaldi profesor
del instituto baker de la universidad
rice de houston amigos el petró no
parece más que una última ocurrencia
para ganar tiempo y tratar de obtener el
mayor número de dólares posibles
aprovechando el tirón de las cripto
monedas y tal vez el blanqueo de
capitales porque quien pondrá los
dólares sobre la mesa
[Música]
el caso es que si ésta es cripto divisa
no funciona y la verdad que eso parece
algo bastante seguro al régimen chavista
de maduro parecen quedarle solo tres
opciones primera a aceptar algún tipo de
revuelta interna y dejar de una o de
otra forma el poder lo que a día de hoy
parece algo muy difícil
la segunda opción sería emplear una mano
aún más dura y condenar al pueblo de
venezuela a un desastre humanitario
incluso mayor y la tercera opción sería
intentar por todos los medios que chinos
y rusos compraran masivamente en los
recursos nacionales del país como por
ejemplo las refinerías el petróleo y
otras muchas materias primas es decir
convertirse en una especie de colonia
mal vendiendo todas y cada una de las
joyas de la corona' para que la élite
chavista pueda seguir disfrutando de su
nivel de vida amigos si algo tengo claro
es que sin nicolás maduró y compañía
continúan en el poder
me parece que venezuela difícilmente
tendrá un futuro mejor pero ahora turno
para ti estarías dispuesto a
y tu dinero por petro déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si te ha resultado
interesante este vídeo darle al botón de
like compártelo con tus amigos y no
olvides suscribirte a visual politics si
aún no lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
construyendo patria paso a paso vamos
transitando el camino
[Música]